That shit crazy.
I actually say that on his album.
He just say I'm bat shit crazy or than Yay and Sarah Pailin.
Oh,
look at this.
Yeah,
that's a real thing.
Oh good Lord.
That's a real thing.
So one side has a t shirt and then the other thing is sewn to the front,
but like it doesn't even,
it looks like it's hanging there.
It is just hanging there.
But it doesn't even look like you're wearing it.
It looks like it's so the point of your shirt,
oh,
what?
Hold on.
Go back to that price.
$1,300 one worse than the tee shirt.
Buy One right now.
Oh my God.
$1,300.
Wow for that.
Do you see Kanye jumped on a table at a university,
was talking about leaving Ilan Musk alone at dues.
Lost his mind,
man.
What's going on?
I don't know man.
You know,
there's a lot of people that speculate and that's all I would say.
This is from me.
Ever since that man's mother died,
he's been on a downward spiral,
like losing his shit.
Well,
uh,
you know,
I think he's suffering from some serious like no bullshit.
He did get into a serious car accident,
right?
Broke his jaw before the series a few years before.
That is not a joke.
No.
Like brain trauma and you listen,
I'm not a doctor or anything even remotely related to one,
but I've been around a lot of people who've been hit in the head a lot.
That shit's real like that.
That will change your brain chemistry.
It's 100% legit like getting hit in the head is no Bueno and car accidents will
fuck people up forever.
Some people,
some people are okay,
they get,
they recover.
Boy,
there was a lot of people that come back for some significant head trauma and
just they're scrambled man and he might be one of those and it also might be
what I talked about in my last special triggered,
but you live with crazy bitches long enough to,
I remember something happens,
you were talking about the soul stealing suck.
You buy it.
It might be true to those,
an amazing routine.
I got to tell you while I was trying to figure out a way that I get away with
making fun of Bruce Jenner without being called transphobic,
I had to go a circuitous route.
It was brilliant.
Go along route two.
First Time I,
yeah,
I had to drag Kanye and that too because this dude,
every book in the mail that's gone into this circle and two,
we lost a mall.
It's spooky.
Yeah,
they are.
Them was like a world champion.
Yes.
Good pull up layer dude.
And he just got cracked out Bush.
What happened to him?
Reggie Bush got wise and fucking failed.
He's got my old car.
He,
Reggie Bush has my 1970 Barracuda.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I sold it to this other dude and this other dude told it to Reggie and he drives
around that car.
It's a dope car and he's a dope car,
you know,
so he's got some taste.
You have any got wise,
weird things are going on over there,
man.
Smashed and bolted.
That's how you do it.
And he's,
he smashed before the fake ass came into the picture too.
That's another phenomenon.
I don't even understand diaper,
but it does is why I'd like a nice round,
but
here's my car.
There's a Reggie Bush driving it.
It was not my card says,
now
look at that Reggie.
Glorious Bastard.
You had her first.
Yeah,
I'm not a really good car.
Really good card.
Look at how to get rid of it.
Oh yeah,
that's the Ray j song.
Right?
You window right there you go.
Full Circle.
You wouldn't want to take second place to read.
You pushed to,
that guy is built like a brick shit house.
You know he was smashing that right.
Whatever he damage he did to that,
he probably was like a car accident.
Maybe all that fake ass shit came after him.
You get hit by that dude I read.
She used to wake up before him and get hot towels ready and put his toothpaste
on his toothbrush.
Smart.
Yeah.
Treat him like a king.
Hey,
probably just smashed it.
She's put all day.
Just delirious.
Just from all the orgasms.
Just walking around,
bumping into walls and shit.
There's a picture of him and her by the pool and you'd look at him when you go,
that guy must be just smashing that he's a super athlete.
I mean that guy is built like a fucking superhero.
All of them.
That's all they really date.
Yeah,
right.
For the most part.
Yeah.
Except Kanye.
She needed to settle down.
Catch a brain behind a a basketball player too.
Right,
right,
right layer.
Do the dude who was on the show all the time,
that guy was on the show all the time.
Crazy living.
I can't even see living your life like out there and fucking public.
Just every fucking pity or business.
Oh,
that would be a nightmare to me.
Well it's also not interesting but yet edited so well that you,
you just go slack jaw and you just watch.
It's just the switch from one scene to another quick enough so that you keep
watching it and when it's over nothing happened.
Nothing.
And you're like,
what the fuck did I do with my hour?
You gave it to them and they advertised like 18 and products that they got paid
for it.
And they made a fucking ass load of money.
When you find out how much that family has made,
you just go,
wait,
wait.
Why?
It's amazing.
Yeah.
I can't,
can't hate can hate you should make fun.
Make Fun all day.
Make Fun all days.
That's it.
That's our God given.
Right when you get that much money.
If I get that much money,
I can't even get mad.
No matter how much fun you make it with me.
No matter what I do,
I could be a saint.
You still can make fun of me cause I got that much money.
Nobody.
That's just the way it goes.
And you are,
I mean you want to talk about someone out there.
Those fucking people are out there.
They got everything out there.
They're living like performance art.
I like living in a giant glass house on a pedestal in the middle of the city.
We're almost,
that's where all that from though.
I was like,
you know the fake ass as a nod.
You gotta just keep the spectacle alive almost.
You know what I mean?
If it's not a spectacle,
it's not interesting.
If it's not an absolute spectacle to the vision,
your,
your brain will catch onto the,
my favorite word fuckery.
Yeah.